des sprints des dépassements des
retournements de situation le
championnat départemental minimes et
cadets a tenu toutes ses promesses
dimanche 19 juin magny les hameaux
pour l'occasion un tracé les 3,2 km a
été dessiné dans le hameau de boétie par
le vélo-club de montigny-le-bretonneux
organisateurs de l'épreuve des coureurs
devaient parcourir la distance dix fois
a tracé sur lequel tout le monde a sa
chance
un homme en forme et n'a pas besoin
d'être spécifiquement un grimpeur s'est
pas c'est simplement un homme costaud
comme il y avait du plat juste après la
côte ne fallait fallait rester au même
rythme et jusqu'au jusqu'à 200 les
difficultés que j'ai rencontrées c'était
le vent et la cote parce qu'il fallait
bien se passer après au total une
centaine de cyclistes classé parmi les
meilleurs du département à participer à
l'événement les sportifs ont réalisé une
moyenne de 32 km heure chez les minimes
et de 34 km h chez les cadets il y avait
des coureurs
qui était bon surtout pour une arrivée
en côte qui aurait pu qui aurait pu me
battre
des gens que je n'y aurais jamais jamais
assez élevé mais
mais bon disons que
en minimes cadets minimes qui sont ban
parmi les meilleurs d'ile-de-france
dillon dans les dix premiers à la sortie
de cette course maxime leroy de conflans
est premier du championnat des yvelines
dans la catégorie cadets et erwan
louvier premier chez les minimes
une nouvelle compétition pourraient être
organisées l'année prochaine par le vélo
club de montigny le bretonneux toujours
à magny les hameaux